let's check in on the state of  liberalism we've got portable  electricity generators powering the  electric cars  with fossil fuels in california what do  we think in the white house what is the  state of liberalism right now from its  most prominent spokesman you know how  much  you know how much i'm going to do with  the deficit this year one trillion five  hundred thousand one trillion five  hundred thousand robber  okay that's that is the state of things  and i think that is probably the most  coherent argument that you could  possibly give in defense of the biden  administration's policies and of  liberalism generally that's it thank you  mr president for selling more copies of  my national best-selling book reasons to  vote for democrats a comprehensive guide  260 blank pages there's really not much  of an argument here the leader of the  free world  cannot speak